mark first question on the left side
mark Schwartz ESPN we often hear about
the Warriors championship pedigree and
feel it how much did you feel Kawhi
Leonard's identity tonight
what areas did he affect this game I
mean he played he played amazing hit
every big shot momentum shot that uh in
that third quarter gave them the lead
and then you know kept the separation so
you know we played pretty well for 26
minutes and and then they you know to
control the game it's one of those
nights where you play a lot of energy
and start to build momentum and the
wheels fall off a little bit so for us
you know just understand they they
played another great game overall the
team not just Kauai and we got to do
something about if we want to you know
extend this series and have another game
here right here in the front clay
Valerio ruby Novi sport basketball is
becoming more and more scientific how do
you find the balance between pushing
your limits on the court and resting
your body also to come back from
injuries is is it more based on your
sensations or on scientific evaluations
I think it's just based on the NBA
Finals and a chance to be at this stage
and compete a lot of guys are banged up
probably on both sigh both teams and
it's just such a special opportunity you
just never know when they'll ever come
back again and obviously the science of
nutrition and sports medicine is an
all-time high right now so we have a
great training staff who was able to get
me back out there
you and Claire have been teammates for
so many years what's the impact he has
had on your career does he make you a
better player team better
he showed that tonight obviously with
you know the injury like that and you
know to come back playing aggressive
hitting big shots and giving us a chance
to you know even be in the game so
obviously he's a gamer and you loved to
go to war with guys like that and we've
been doing it for a long time
damn standing it back right back here
Dan Devine from the ringer guys you've
been in this uncomfortable position
before and been able to come back out of
three one down what can you draw from
that experience in 2016 as you tried to
get back on the right track here that's
not over I mean this is just not a good
feeling right now obviously but like you
said we've been on both sides of it and
for us it's an opportunity for us to you
know just flip this whole series on his
head and and you got to do it one game
at a time it sounds cliche and and for
us that's literally the only way we're
going to get you know back in the series
is give everything we got for 48 minutes
everybody that steps foot on that floor
in Game five and our locker room we were
talking about believing they out there
you know believe that we can get this
done and we got said we can draw in
those experiences that we had you know
back in the dead draw and those
experiences that we had you know back in
the day and and see what happens in the
back
staff Ron Carter from the San Francisco
Chronicle um you guys talk a lot about
rhythm in your offense and your shooting
it seemed like you never really found
your rhythm much tonight especially in
contrast to two nights ago why do you
think that was and did the Raptors try
anything different on you in the wake of
your big game the other night I mean not
really they've been aggressive all
series and trying to take you know space
away from me and clay I missed some
shots early that usually make especially
you know from the three-point line but
overall I feel like I got you know good
looks and obviously I'm sure they were a
little bit more you know focused on I
want us to consider how game three went
and having a great game playing so still
look at the film figure out how can make
you know the right decisions with the
ball of my hands and be aggressive and
assertive and make those adjustments for
getting far towards the center hey clay
so how much do you think your Hamm
Street has effective game tonight even
though you got a great game with 28
points but did you still feel the pain
and plays through it because we saw you
kind of lean when you get off the court
it didn't affect me and like I said
before mr. Finals it's a long season you
play a hundred plus games you're gonna
be banged up but she's got a dig deep I
mean no one's gonna feel sorry for you
so you've got to go out there man up and
play the best of your ability Phil again
towards the middle hey Steph Phil barber
Santa Rosa Press Democrat just to your
right I'm sure that nobody is is thrown
in the towel in any way like you said
you're gonna look at the film and come
up with some answers but I'm wondering
just considering the stakes tonight and
the history of what you guys have done
in this building is there a certain
amount of shock at tonight's result not
really we we try to win every game we
play is I mean we don't you don't
succeed the way we have over the course
of these years without that mentality so
you know as second half unfolds and
things aren't going our way well you
know we're still like we said fighting
and trying to you know get over the hump
but you know until the final buzzer
sounds if somebody gets to four wins we
still you know have life and having an
opportunity to to win so like clay said
nobody's gonna feel sorry for us at all
it's just a matter of can we get it done
or not and we're gonna leave it all out
there
you know starting on Monday Dan last
question here on the right side guys Dan
Waikiki with the Los Angeles I'm sure it
over over these last five years you guys
have put so many teams away with with
big runs but it seemed like every time
you would have a 3:05 o run tonight they
responded what is it about them do you
think makes them equipped to kind of
handle those pushes from you guys
they're a good nerve great team in the
NBA Finals I mean I got a lot of
everyone knows their role they got a lot
of experience guys we've been here
before
and I mean hopefully you know game five
we got bigger runs and they can't close
the gap but that's just basketball you
got a game credit thanks guys Fremont
will be up next